congratulations professor Arnold thank
you so much
what has today been like it's a magical
Odyssey a celebration of what I love
best which is science how wonderful is
that that's wonderful you you have a
background as a mechanical and an
aerospace engineer and then you turned
toward proteins that's an interesting
step from big stuff to small stuff
how has your background affected your
research Engineers love to solve
problems and I think that that mindset
really set the way that I approached
engineering the biological world it's
very hard to do that and do better than
evolution but as an engineer I could
come in and say here are the features we
want to have what's the best process
that was already invented by Nature it's
called evolution you brought some
different ideas how you think we're
different backgrounds as well well I
brought in the desire to use this to do
something beneficial for society for the
planet and for the future and as many
noble Lords you have also experienced
criticism people who didn't think of
your science your work as science what
kept you going then
oh well scientists get criticism all the
time it's part of the scientific method
but we have to learn how to take the
criticism the parts that are useful and
use those to improve and just set aside
all the parts that are not so useful so
what keeps me going is that ability to
recognize what I can take from that and
to completely ignore the rest
sounds like a good recipe you meet young
students occasionally in what way are
they a source of inspiration to you the
young students
there they have this joy of science and
they have no boundaries right no one has
ever told them or they haven't heard it
yet that you can't do this that you
can't achieve that they still think
everything is possible and it's my job
as an older scientist to make that dream
flower and to make that possible so
what's your advice to young students
today stay in science it's the best
possible career to have something joyful
every day and to use your brains to
better the world or to discover
knowledge that's never been discovered
before how could you do better than that
thank you very very much because they're
on and enjoy this evening
I intend to